bueno vayan busca precisamente mostrar
esa diversidad que tiene hoy la sociedad
estadounidense mostramos muestra
básicamente señalar que ya no es una
sociedad sólo de hombres blancos de
origen fundamentalmente europeo sino que
hay una población latina latina ya
americana que hay una población por
supuesto negra descendiente de los
esclavos también por parte constitutiva
de la sociedad americana y lo muestra en
este gabinete y también creo que mostró
tanto la forma austera de la
presentación en el tipo de
personalidades los discursos que
hicieron demostró también en la forma
que va a hacer un gabinete de gente
experimentada profesional frente a lo
que han sido los gabinetes de donald
trump mariano hablemos ahora de la
política exterior cómo estaría enfocada
a la diplomacia de joe biden frente a la
que hemos visto estos últimos años con
el presidente donald trump al mando de
la casa blanca
fundamentalmente él va a ser una
política como dijeron ayer sus
funcionarios futuros una política de
regreso al multilateralismo en el cual
eeuu sigue manteniendo ese discurso que
siempre ha tenido del liderazgo pero
dejando en claro que asumen como ya lo
había asumido la administración obama y
muchos de ellos vienen de la
administración obama de que es necesario
gestionar el sistema internacional junto
con otros o sea eeuu asume que ya no
puede mandar sobre el sistema
internacional sino que tiene que
compartir poder y gestionar
conjuntamente como podemos ver estos
cuatro años que le avecinan a joe biden
en torno a la política interior de eeuu
como usted bien lo dijo también bailen
con estos nombramientos se quiere reunir
el país lo puede lograr en estos tiempos
de polarización y crítica en eeuu
pero que no sea del país está
francamente fuertemente dividido
en casi un 50 50 por ciento veo muy
difícil que él pueda lograr
digamos unificar al país lo va a
intentar tiene la capacidad de tiene el
equipo y tiene políticas para tratar de
unificar lo pero creo que posiblemente
va a poder hacer más con todas las
dificultades del mundo nunca mejor dicho
va a poder hacer más en política
exterior que la interior en el interior
va a tener muchísimas trabas muchísimos
obstáculos y muchísima oposición señora
aguirre gracias por su tiempo y por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24 que
tenga usted un feliz resto de día en
noruega